picture for the cubs today is the big
right-hander
jake arietta a sinker he leans heavily
on that pitch off to a really good start
three and one eight 286 earned run
average in four starts colton long to
lead things off rose wong hits one in
the air into left center field and
that's going to find the gap colt wong
oh he is swinging a red hot bat coming
off the injured list and he starts today
with a double omar narvaez at the plates
narvaez with a base head into left field
and wong will hold up at third so
quickly the brewers with a thread
runners at the corners to start the game
and now obviously garcia
missed with a two-seamer and the brewers
have them loaded with nobody out here in
the first so a full-blown jam right away
against jake arrieta base has loaded
nobody out and travis shaw the cleanup
hitter coming up again the 3-2
and
just missed inside and a walk will
force
colton wong home as it just did miss wow
risky take good take for travis shaw and
the hitter will be casting hero popped
up shallow right
infield fly rule in effect rizzo
squeezes out number one that's as good
as a strikeout one away and it brings up
billy mckinney
swinging a miss strike three arietta
gets the strikeout and a big one it was
now there are two down jackie bradley jr
coming up against arietta this is a very
big at-bat in terms of overall game
momentum you're already down one to a
guy who can be very dominant brandon
woodruff you don't want to get much
further behind ground
to short right corner has it flips to
first
and jake arietta limits the damage the
first four brewers reached they pushed
one run across but milwaukee leads the
bases loaded brandon woodruff start
number five he is 1-0
with a 196 e all ray
has yet to beat the cubs in his career
10 games eight starts and a 3 48 earned
run average
at the plate swing and a miss
97 takes care of ian hatford out number
one here's david bodie 2-2
and a fly ball to rights no trouble for
abi garcia two up two down now it's
anthony rizzo grounded back towards the
middle over the bag robertson has it
throws to first in time and the inning
is over he goes one two three through
the cubs in the bottom of the first and
here is
brandon woodruff last time he hit
against the cubs it excited a little
tension between the two teams woodruff
hard hit ground ball oh diving backhand
stop horner throws to first in time to
get woodruff
what a play by horner ranging to his
right diving backhand stopped up on his
feet and fired a bullseye for a strike
to rizzo two away brandon woodruff
retired the side in order in the first
chris bryant leading things off
again the one-two
got him on the breaking goal for out
number one second strikeout for brandon
woodruff that was deadly that fell
straight off the table and here's javi
baez
well back into center field jbj with
enough room and with a little help from
the wind that is out number two wrong
day to center field
big win blowing in
wrigley field giveth wrigley field take
it away brandon woodruff has pitched
well thus far it's been six up and six
down against him roman is swinging a
miss
and woodruff has retired the first eight
third strikeout for woodruff order of
coming home with the pitch
and he got a call third strike strikeout
number four for brandon woodruff he goes
through the cubs one two three it's been
nine up nine down so far for chicago
cubs in business a lead off walk to half
a single by boate men on first and
second woodruff in his first jam of the
day and it'll bring up anthony rizzo
struck him out with a high fastball big
strikeout rizzo not pleased and now it's
chris brian woodruff throws runner goes
swinging to miss throw to third in time
strike him out throw him out double play
gets woodruff out of a jam in the fourth
by his aggressive thought he could short
hop it and maybe start a six four three
double play
boy that could change the complexion of
this inning big time second and third
nobody else that is a big problem for
jake arrieta shot the plate swag and a
missed right three a beautiful slow
curve ball out number one
sixth punch out of the game for jake
heston herrera the battle swing
[Music]
back-to-back strikeouts for jake arietta
two down in the batter now is billy
mckinney swinging on this strike three
what a job by jake arrieta
helps get out of the gym duffy moves
over to third but now there are two down
brandon woodruff now he gets a date with
anthony rizzo struck him out with a high
fastball
eight strikeouts in six shutout innings
at wrigley for brandon woodruff
two away and bradley cannot advance so
he stays at second and it's going to be
up to colton wong the 3-2
big chopper gonna be a tough play mills
has to hurry throws to first gets him no
runs for milwaukee still a one-nothing
brewer lead cubs have the tying run on
base with just one away here in the
seventh inning and jason hayward do up
fire eisen looking in here's the pitch
swinging a miss got him with another
chain job little emotion from fire eisen
after the strikeout of hayward that will
bring up nico horner the 2-2 swing of
the miss got him with the chain job
fire rising with back-to-back strikeouts
to end the seventh
and a lead-off single to begin the
eighth for narvaez and the brewers the
batter is avasayo garcia right side
horner lets it drop throws to first they
get one and now they've got narvaez in a
rundown baez chases him gives to rizzo
off to horner the tag he's out double
play what a play by nico horner bases
are loaded
again with nobody out for the second
time in this game luis urias is the
batter jason adam with a one strike
pitch and there's a shot in the center
field and base hit two-run knock by
louis
three-nothing brewers fulton wong at the
plate swinging a line drive fair down
the right field line robertson is in
four or nothing brewers and now the
eighth batter to hit in the inning will
be travis shaw
and did they get him rbi the hard way
yes sir
and a run will score
make it five nothing brewers here's
tyrone taylor as a pinch batter and
another run is in a bases loaded walk
and a hot mess of a ninth inning for the
cubs bullpen to make it six nothing two
down it's up to bias to keep the cubs
alive today
going after the first pitch and a fly
ball hit into center field jackie
bradley jr is there the brewers win the
series and they take five out of six in
this road trip
in shutout fashion today six to nothing